the status addict looks for the next
chair like a drug addict craving drugs
as the body develops a tolerance for
narcotic substances and the person seeks
higher doses the status addict looks for
an increase in interest and respect from
others welcome back to our next episode
of the series called language shapes
perception today we're talking about the
addiction of status
[Music]
please
known than drug addictions
status addiction can cause serious harm
to individuals and Society one of the
essential mistakes some people make when
they attain a certain status is their
failure to see how transitory worldly
positions are they act as if this world
is permanent why do some people's
characters change when they are promoted
to a certain position why do some
character flaws Surface after gaining a
certain status it is known that the
human carnal Soul has different forms of
weakness and is inclined to develop
certain forms of worldly addictions and
love of status is one of them when a
person comes to a high position he or
she often gains a different mood with
the new power and means they've obtained
sometimes this means maintaining one's
internal balance and sometimes it means
losing that balance the latter situation
might stem from negative feelings that
had until then been suppressed
some people develop an addiction to
substances that stimulate their sense of
reward in time
psychological addiction is accompanied
by the biological addiction and the does
demanded for satisfaction increases if
it is not achieved feelings of
deprivation can arise and from this
crises surface consequently the person
becomes totally addicted addiction for
status develops in the same pattern the
only difference is that what causes the
addiction is not a chemical substance
but the status itself the person is
virtually drugged with the effects of
power and the opportunities in hand
along with the respect and interest
shown by others therefore one does not
only fear losing the opportunities but
also this respect and interest the
person does whatever one can in order to
make things continue as they are similar
to a drug addict who resorts to a legal
means for the sake of finding drugs the
person will use any means to retain
power what matters is only the
continuity of the position and the
status possessed after one chair the
status addict looks for the next chair
like a drug addict craving drugs as the
body develops a tolerance for narcotic
substances and the person seeks higher
doses the status addict looks for an
increase in interest and respect from
others the least degree of indifference
or being normal treatment makes the
status lover lose their temper for this
reason he does not like to keep around
those who fail to show excessive respect
and who make occasional warnings about
his behavior he continually looks for
people to behave like servants at his
beck and call in the end the status
lover will be surrounded by flatterers
instead of sound advisors who might
bring him to his senses this only adds
to his pleasure more as he needs higher
doses for satisfaction people with good
qualifications
whom appeared to be potential Rivals
evoke a great disturbance in status
addicts such individuals are quickly
destroyed before they can prove
themselves therefore both the addict's
position is retained and the ones who
might discover their mistakes are
handled status addicts sometimes make
unjust decisions and enforce them for
the sake of intimidation he is the most
successful and rightful person because
his own potential and intelligence come
before everything consultation and
meetings are routine tasks to let pass
the status addict does not accept
anybody's opinion but his own does not
listen to different ideas and uses
meetings as shows of power to satisfy
his ego after some time this dizzying
mood causes serious mistakes however as
nobody to bring them to their senses
Remains the consequences are Grim the
treatment process for status addicts
requires balancing the heart and mind
and also activating the spiritual
Dynamics otherwise the person totally
goes astray both materially and
spiritually the egotistic behavior of
the status addict harms the addict first
of all and also harms those around them
all worldly positions are temporary and
being aware of this might be helpful in
treating status addiction God Almighty
will call people to account for all of
the blessings he gave there are other
people who are more talented or who have
better capacities than we do graveyards
are full of people who once assumed that
everything depended on them when one is
dismissed from a certain position the
extremeness of that person's reaction is
in direct proportion with the degree of
addiction all that matters here is a
person's continuing one's relation with
God not upsetting the balance of the
heart not forgetting that this world is
temporary and giving this world and the
next as much value as they deserve
thanks for listening to language shapes
perception I hope you enjoyed our dive
into this modest elaboration
if you're Keen to see these ideas can be
applied in your beautiful lives
join us next week when we'll be
recording our next episode tackling our
next topic as always you can head over
to our YouTube channel to sign up to our
email list as well as check out all the
links and resources in the show notes
that's all for this episode see you next
time
[Music]
foreign